no you're not applying sighs I'm not
applying myself don't feel you're
applying all right most you can 100%
activity just ends out back again for
the sport Bible and contrary to popular
belief I know absolutely nothing about
rugby I know three boys who do
[Music]
very important as well put your arms
working working like that comment give
you a big you know the sidestep to learn
for me I'll leave it to you boys but
next one parse it should be simple right
[Laughter]
[Music]
good positivity negativity that was
alright on a Scoon right will go for a
light heart jump with the line that jump
you got brace you phrase to tell about
British cool no gets good alright I'm
fine
not your point I'm not applying myself
no Phil you're applying sorry the
trousers I need a good frozen shoot take
a nap retracts upon I am very
fashionable better than the other loose
ones we shape you felt that's why you
standard well you landed low I'm doing
it free pros mark I serve the ball
that's the main thing as you can see
even with lessons from the very best
England has to offer
but listen you boys good luck with the
rest
Justin's up for the sport Bible and I've
not been very good at running
[Music]